let's jump into the first story
Southwest Airlines from CNBC Southwest
drops plan to put unvaccinated staff on
unpaid leave starting in December
Southwest scrapped a plan
to put their unvaccinated workers with
pending exemptions on unpaid leave after
the December 8th deadline both American
and Southwest require their new hire
employees to show proof of covid-19
vaccination before their first day large
airlines are federal contractors and
subject to to a Biden Administration
order that requires their employees to
be vaccinated or receive an exemption
for medical or religious reasons now I
can respect the the exemptions for
medical and religious reasons the
problem is a lot of these companies are
just outright denying them no matter
what but this is a different case here
because there's reports of Southwest
Executives literally going around the
company asking people to please get the
exemption paperwork please fill it out
either for medical or religious purposes
they want so there's been an effort that
people are reporting that that they want
them to get these exceptions but this is
a huge announcement this is big I mean
they're pretty much announcing that
they're not going to be going along with
this Tim you disagree with uh disagree
disagree here but they're not going to
fire employees or in other words put
them on paid leave if they don't get
vaccinated they're not going to do that
that's a huge step to me that has been
demonstrated through the freedom flu
through all the protests through all the
demonstrations and through all the
massive disruptions that we saw a couple
days ago
the people opposing the mandates are are
gaining ground so this is a battle being
won but the war is still very of course
100 and here's you got to understand
when they say new hires are still under
the vax Mandate they're basically going
to appease those who currently work
they're saying well doesn't affect me
anymore so I'm good yeah and then new
employees will have to be mandated so
what happens in 10 20 years the vax
Mandate stands we'll see how long the
vax mandates are going to be implemented
I I definitely agree with you a lot of
people think they're going to be
temporary as long as covid's going to be
around but as mean you know and a lot of
other people know this is a long game
it's not going to be ending anytime soon
it benefits too many people it benefits
to many billionaires for it to stop but
this is still a major victory because
the workers United here came together
and said hey we don't like this policy
we don't want it go ahead I mean there
were some protests but we basically just
saw people disorganized being like nah
exactly it was scarier to this company
yeah Southwest is like we're gonna do
this mandate oh Biden's making us do it
and then a bunch of employees just
called in sick well they knew and
organized they knew forcing this would
be worse for them than not forcing it so
this realization that's the big story to
me and that's why I led with it that's
why I've been talking about it all day
because this is this is huge and uh
there's going to be reverberations of
this all over the place because now
people know that their voice actually
matters when they come together and they
speak up together as long as they don't
back down exactly and because because I
I genuinely think most people the
smartest thing they could do was oh only
new hires have to be vaccinated
because then people who already hired
it's going to be like I'm good yeah
later down the line that's going to have
its effects doing it right now exactly
so the vaccine mandates there this is an
attempt to redirect
but it's probably still going to happen
it's probably still going to happen and
I and I'll tell you I really don't think
that the vaccines are the are the are
the goal of the Mandate as you know
people who listen probably have heard me
say a million times because if you look
at the Chicago Police they're like if
you try and retire right now instead of
getting vaccinated we will take your
benefits we'll go after your benefits so
very clearly they're just trying to
force people you know it's about the
Mandate not about the vaccine part of it
uh also it's also important in that
specific case that a judge actually put
up put a restraining order on the the
Chicago Police Union Chief that's
barring him from talking about the
vaccine publicly so this is a major
fight that's happening between the
police Union the mayor of Chicago and
this is not just in Chicago there was
also police and firefighters today in
Seattle that decided that they were
going to feed the Homeless because they
were fired from their public service
jobs and they came out they went on the
steps of City Hall took off their boots
left them there at City Hall so there's
been a lot of different demonstrations
there's been a lot of big protests in
California a lot of people took their
kids out of school today because the
kids are mandated to be vaccinated and
they took them to a protest and there
was protests all over California saying
no we're not going along with these
mandates here's one of the things
interesting about Southwest is that
initially they denied there was any kind
of sick out right right not happening
then all of a sudden the CEO comes out
and I we didn't we didn't want to do a
mandate Biden made us do it and it's
kind of like why are you bringing up
mandates I thought the narrative was
that there was no you know that there
was no protest or anything about this so
they're clearly trying to now blame you
know uh Joe Biden but I'm wondering
Michael what you think about
you know do you think Trump would have
done something similar is this an issue
of progressives and acting policies that
are damaging to business and First
Responders I mean I at this point
honestly what freaks me out is that
we've had such a morale hit for the
police in the United States over the
last year and a half ever since the
George Floyd protests you know we've
lost you know a lot of these police
forces are understaffed right now one of
the things that I became very was I was
so surprised to find was that the
evidence of the importance of police
because I come from the left and so I've
always been somewhat skeptical of the
police as part of the criminal justice
establishment but the evidence that
police prevent homicides is just really
strong and the relationship between cops
and potential Killers just interacting
with them every day in the neighborhood
very strong evidence that works and so
after 2015 after the Ferguson protests
there was a pretty sharp increase in
homicides one of the police chief and
Ferguson said we're calling this the
Ferguson effect because we think that
both the cops are pulling back from
their policing and the criminals are
more emboldened a lot of people on the
left dismissed that but we saw it again
after the George Floyd protest last year
so clearly anything that
um that would basically dampen the
morale of police right now I think would
contribute to increasing crime
I mean it's just at the federal level
Federal contractors federal employees
right
so it's
I don't know is it just a direct
correlation between this is affecting
the morale of the officers or is this
just failed policy
I mean we we I I I'm a little bit I'm on
the fence on this one I mean I'm
vaccinated I think vaccines are
important I also think that this issue
is sort of there's no real explanation
of what the end game here is you know
like how long are we wearing masks for
what is it going to be to deal with
vaccine requirements forever hasn't felt
like we've had a proper conversation
about it
um I mean we do all the time and you
know the funny thing is 15 days to slow
the spread has quickly turned into
nearly two years of harsh restrictions
mandates requirements and there's one
prediction right now that what's going
to happen is there will be a wave of
fake vaccine cards we've already seen
some stories and then all of a sudden
you're hearing the media people want
digital passports and they've already
started making them and then what really
happens is a social credit system
so they'll they track more than just
your your vaccine like the one of the
reasons I'm I'm very much opposed to
this is they're they're trying they're
they're trying to use something that
most people find reasonable like getting
a vaccine I've got a ton you know I've
traveled all over so I just had to get
all these cards and you know when you go
to Venezuela you need one and then
they're going to use that as they're in
to get you to carry your passport what
are they doing in New York you need your
ID as well as your your medical card
well for a lot of people it's going to
be easier just to download the app
what's the app gonna do the app's gonna
track you in in many many different ways
it's going to give the government access
to data that you know only Facebook has
for instance and shouldn't yeah so
that's well for me this is a big loyalty
test because a lot of officers who are
skeptical of the federal government who
want bodily autonomy who think that they
should have the right to decide what is
right for them there's a lot of people
who are vaccinated who are against the
vaccine mandates that are still not even
uh talked about widely and publicly but
there's a big sector of these
individuals out there so you know we had
a guest on a couple days ago that said
it's very easy to fake a lot of this
compliance a lot of these passports and
the people who are standing up the
people who are vocal are deciding to do
it on principles are deciding to do it
on morale and that's why seeing a lot of
these officers being purged a lot of
these officers being fired only will
help I believe the federal government in
the long run because they'll have more
compliant officers that will always do
what they want them to do no matter what
the consequences are and you always
start with something little and you keep
escalating it that's why we started with
you know just just two weeks to stay
home and then masks and then vaccines
and then second vaccines and then
passport systems and now booster shots
and then it's only going to get worse
from here unless the American people
stand up and say enough is enough we're
not going along with this and that's why
I think this southwest story is so big
it deserves a lot more uh mentions and
someone in the comment section wrote
that Southwest decided to do this
because of the the weather conditions
which I thought was absolutely hilarious
because that was their initial line Jen
saki said that nothing existed that that
this wasn't a protest nothing was
happening here well obviously it was
because why did Southwest change their
major decision here so these are going
to have far-reaching implications not
with just with the police not just in
the corporate world but this is I think
deliberately done as a loyalty test to
see who's going to obey government the
most and so your vision is basically we
should just you know basically have no
vaccine requirements no vaccine mandates
no Max no Mass requirements and just
make it like the flu shot in other words
if you want to get the flu shot you get
the flu shot same thing with coronavirus
yeah I I certainly think so we had a
really interesting conversation you know
Ian asked about the the morality of
mandates like what if you had Ebola
there's a good question and I'm like it
is tough I think with like an Airborne
Ebola with like as massively high
infectivity and you you'd like it would
self-regulate in a lot of ways but
ultimately regardless of whether or not
it does I think
even with if that is the case we
shouldn't have mandates it should
self-regulate people should say I'm
concerned about this I will protect
myself but now all of a sudden we're
getting just the argument changes every
single time it comes out right first uh
you know fauci has said has gone back
and forth on masks I think two or three
times he he went back and forth on
double masking a couple times then the
CDs he said wear double masks and I
think a lot of people at this point are
just like when you get a fouchie coming
out who can't give you a straight answer
but he keeps being touted and championed
eventually people just say enough
one of the biggest issues with the with
the uh the mandates is it's forcing
people to disclose medical conditions
it's forcing people to disclose private
personal details and if you're concerned
about it you need to assume the risks of
your life to go out and live and work
from the from the beginning one of the
problems we've seen with uh with Cobin
is that we've decided to do a
one-size-fits-all approach to literally
everything hey the the people above 40
are the highest risk factor so let's
lock down everything including schools
and now we're in a major economic crisis
which is only being exacerbated by
ridiculous Joe Biden policies and
ignorance and people judge being on
vacation so it's they're really good at
making things worse maybe we should have
had a surgical approach where we said
okay if you're in a vulnerable
population we'll we'll do special
accommodations we'll do what we can to
have skeleton Crews keeping the economy
running so we don't just shut everything
down but we went one size fits all now
we're doing the same thing and you'll
have people who have very deep religious
or moral convictions as to why they're
not interested in this notably the the
the use of fetal cells in the
experimentation process for the Pfizer
vaccine and Johnson Johnson uses fetal
cells for the growth of the virus to
produce it I can certainly understand
why a lot of people are like you cannot
force me to to take something like that
and then you have medical conditions in
which already in New York there's no
exceptions for medical conditions and
many of these businesses are saying oh
your doctor said no we reject that that
logic and so I'm seeing stories of uh we
had this woman I believe it was from
ESPN who said that she's trying to have
a baby with her husband and for that
she's been recommended not to get the I
believe that's what it is well she says
she's not going to be in the vaccine and
I said we don't care whether you want to
have a kid or not there have been there
have been a few stories of women who
have said their doctors advised them not
to get the vaccine while they're
currently or about to you know try and
have a kid even though I think the FDA
said it's it's safe for when we're
pregnant their doctor still gave them
personal advice based on maybe their
blood pressure and now because of the
FDA because of the establishment these
women are being told choose to have a
kid or quit your job like this whole
thing is completely broken that's why
I'm like it's bad across the board and
where do you stand what about things
like uh measles vaccines that are
mandated for kids before chronovirus
obviously is what's going on or polio
what about those vaccines yeah so those
are particularly different but there's
there's an interesting overlap I would
oppose in in some respects vaccine
mandates in that area however we're
talking about vaccines that have been
tested for for decades for you know uh
some of the production of some of these
is 20 30 years and they were these
mandates were all implemented through
long legislative processes as opposed to
the mayor said do it or else the
President says do it or else and now
people who are trying to get you know
legitimate
um exemptions are being told no and now
the interesting thing is that that this
is all starting this is why again man
talk about bad policy from Democrats by
mandating this uh uh the coveted vaccine
which is just entering now the long-term
trials according to the FDA insert for
the community vaccine you have people
now looking into MMR vaccines and the
other uh you know other standard
vaccines and they're discovering that
not only do we use fetal cells in the
production of the viruses from aborted
babies we're learning that they use that
for like ibuprofen and stuff so now
you're getting people actually start
starting to challenge past vaccine
mandates which most of us didn't have a
problem with because we were like
long-standing research legislative
process legislative approach okay some
of us don't like that it's happening but
we agree we went through that process
now you have Bill de Blasio being like
do it or else with no exemptions and so
you get people who have underlying
medical conditions being denied access
to restaurants you have people who are
just concerned about trusting the
government namely a lot of people in the
black community Billy prempe made a
great video talking about why the black
community is untrusting of this they're
being told they can't go into these
these businesses and now because of the
politics of it you actually have
Republicans saying maybe we should look
into all of the mandates and I'm like oh
geez yeah I mean they've been lying
through their teeth about so many of
these issues they've been flip-flopping
they've been inconsistent they've been
censoring scientists they've been
censoring studies they've been censoring
actual real debate that we never had
about this faucio only does softball
interviews where they uh a
family-friendly show uh pleasure him
with her words in in many different
possible ways that I never thought was
even possible so so when we're not even
having a real conversation when we're
told 100 percent safe and effective and
then we're finding out oh three percent
after a few months and and and a lot of
the data that's still coming that we
don't know it brings up a lot more
questions than answers but but to kind
of put the question back on to you that
you asked Tim how would you approach
everything well yeah I mean here's the
thing guys I'm not a great person to ask
about this because I as soon as covid
hit I decided to work on this book and
that was like I'm flat out on this book
it was drugs crime homelessness for the
last several hundred years all I would
say is I think it was interesting
because of course we have two mental
models of vaccines one is you know as a
parent I've got two kids uh both have
been through school already but you know
you have to get vaccines to go to public
schools but then you have a flu vaccine
you know every year we get the the you
know the shot for the flu vaccine that's
not mandate that's not mandated so we
have two different models so it's kind
of like coronavirus like polio and
measles or is it like a flu obviously
it's it's probably somewhere in between
yeah that's interesting long covet is is
interesting because you've got these
lingering health effects and that's why
they're saying okay you know maybe
people should get this
I don't think you know I'll I'll put it
this way while covet is very obviously
serious and dangerous somewhere in
between I think is a good way to put it
I look at the data and I'm just like I
don't see this as being on that level of
mandating vaccines for this but more
importantly you know
you can choose not to bring put your kid
in in these schools you can go to
private schools you can go other places
you can homeschool to say you can't go
to a restaurant or hold a job is where
we're starting to get very serious
because right now this this is really
where the big dividing line is you could
go and get a job anywhere and they're
not going to demand your medical papers
you know they'll ask for your government
papers which already is you know pretty
interesting I think there should be an
argument about that but now we're
getting to the point where it's if you
want to get a job you have to undergo a
statemented medical procedure and that's
where I'm like yeah I'm not a big fan of
that it's one thing to be like this is
School
you don't have to put your kid in the
school you can find other ways to
educate your kid
now they're saying well go [ __ ] you know
if if you've got Joe Biden doing Federal
mandates if you've got New York City
doing city-wide mandates that's passing
just you know business mandates now as
for private businesses there's a there's
an interesting argument here and I think
non-discrimination is where it becomes
uh there's a question about whether or
not a business like Southwest could do
this so uh does a business have a right
to discriminate on the basis of medical
or religious uh practices and the answer
is no overwhelmingly no I know that
conservatives uh
used to be on the other side of this to
a great degree like you know the famous
story of the baker the argument was the
baker was going to be was told he had to
write a message he didn't want to write
and said he had ended up winning on Free
Speech grounds I guess but they still
harass him the left does
so I've always been on the side of if
you're using public spaces funded by the
public you have a right to serve the
public and provide public combination to
everyone you can't make up arbitrary
reasons to discriminate if someone comes
in screaming or threatening people Yeah
by all means kick them out if someone's
got a disability I don't think you
should be able to to say no however what
are we seeing in for with a lot of these
companies they don't care about what
your doctor said what are we seeing in
New York in New York I called a couple
dozen restaurants who outright told me
they did not care if you had a
disability barring vaccination like
maybe you have Guillain-Barre syndrome
like the drummer from The Offspring he
got kicked out of the band because he
could not get the vaccine due to
Guillain-Barre syndrome so this is where
people have just straight up been like
we have now violated the Americans with
Disabilities Act we don't care and no
one will enforce it I just not a fan
yeah I mean it seems like you have these
two extremes between Australia and
Sweden you know that have been sort of
out there as these two visible mental
models and I mean what I can what I
totally agree with is is the idea that
Americans are really bad at this is some
of the points I make in San Francisco
were just bad at the gray areas and a
more surgical approach to these things
we just tend to be it tends to be an on
or off switch for us yeah I I definitely
agree with that assessment because from
the very beginning there was so much
fear-mongering there was so much drama
there was so much emotional and
manipulation that literally people shut
down and Democratic politicians and also
other politicians said close down those
small mom and pop businesses police
officers run around shut down those
businesses meanwhile the big
multinational corporations were allowed
to be open the whole time and I think to
add to your point that's why there was
also a sentiment against the police
officers that was very negative on the
right because of that and they didn't
get a lot of support when black lives
matter kicked up during that summer
because because everyone's like these
are the same guys that kick down my door
and shut down my business while allowing
Walmart and Costco to do whatever they
wanted to so where does this end it
doesn't there's too many billionaires
benefiting from it it's going to proceed
to lead to a situation that we're seeing
in Australia that we're seeing in Italy
there's a viral video that I played in
my uh in my YouTube video today of an
old grandma outside of a hospital and a
security guard is kicking her out and
he's like I want the I want you know he
wants the vax Mandate she didn't have
the right paperwork she needed treatment
at the hospital she couldn't get it she
was told to go away and she her elderly
grandmother walked away yeah because she
didn't have the paperwork but she was
vaccinated I have no idea about that but
these are the vaccine mandates you don't
have your paperwork you can't get food
you can't you can't get services that
are basic human rights services that
shouldn't be denied to anyone and this
is going to lead to an Australian
italian-like situation thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast
if you want to watch live you can check
out this channel Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this Channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time